Twitter tells you something an
influencer tells you something a
politician tells you something a news
organization tells you something what do
they want to get out of that they want a
response so you're being manipulated
right there so at least just to
recognize that before immediately
getting angry and retweeting something
well hey take a breath you owe it to
that person who sacrificed everything in
the Revolutionary War in the Civil War
in World War One in World War II you
could have these freedoms well take a
breath for them and study the issue a
little bit
you are somebody that is ex-military
service now an author you have the
opportunity to write out scenarios that
may be inspired by stuff that you went
through and stuff that's complete
fantasy as well how therapeutic do you
find the process of being able to
dispose of bad guys with as much uh
inventiveness as you want and no
restrictions at all right well I joke
that it keeps me out of prison and
that's only half joking I think because
it is extremely therapeutic and our
senior level military leaders and
elected politicians give me a lot to
work with the world in general gives me
a lot to work with these days but at the
outset I didn't really realize that it
was going to be something that was
therapeutic or something that was
intensely personal I thought I'd get the
sniper weapon stuff right and if I
didn't know who to talk to or if I
didn't know something about some sort of
a tank or a plane or something I at
least knew who I could call to ask these
questions
um but as soon as I started writing and
not even in the coming up in the title
coming up with a theme coming up with a
one-page executive summary memory
getting the outline done it wasn't until
I wrote the first words that I realized
oh this is going to be extremely
personal and not so much in the fact
that I am recreating exact scenarios
that happened in Iraq or Afghanistan but
more so that if I have my character gets
ambushed in Los Angeles California as
part of a completely fictional narrative
I go back and remember what it was like
to be ambushed in Baghdad 2006 and I
take those feelings and emotions and
apply them to a completely fictional
storyline so that was personal and then
a lot of the other things that come in
that are not so dramatic as that that
just help the story move forward to down
to the the uh the type of car that my
protagonist drives and his wife drives
um like that sort of a thing just those
little personal the kind of music that
his wife listens to and listened to
um uh in the first book so all those
little things really ended up making it
very personal as did the uh the more
dramatic uh action sequences where I go
back and remember what it was like to be
a sniper in ramadi and then just take
that and plop it into the fictional
narrative take us through that ambush in
2006. yeah so that was a interesting one
because a week prior we had um tracked
somebody into a mosque and I was working
with uh the CIA at the time I was the
only military guy attached to them which
was fantastic because the uh I guess the
Baroque bureaucracy that's overhead was
a lot less it seemed like over there at
least it was to me at my level for what
I was doing but we tracked somebody that
was on our Target list into a mosque and
uh we went in after them
um and I should say it was what the
Iraqis we were working with really went
in attribute at that time it was a
sovereign country Iraq
um and yet we still got in quite a bit
of trouble for doing that
um even though our guys didn't even
really go inside
um and so it was about a week later I
think that we're tracking somebody else
using both Technical and human
intelligence means uh at night in
Baghdad and uh and track him once again
and into a mosque but now because of the
big uproar over us getting in trouble
just a week or two prior so we park
outside and our profile at the time
wasn't the military type profile and
this is after the the golden mosque uh
bombing so tension so he turned into
Sunni Shia Civil War out there and the
profile of our vehicles I mean it could
have been mistaken for uh for one or the
other
um but uh so we sat there parked and
waiting to get approval to go in to this
mosque and I think I had to go very high
up the chain because we were waiting a
long time and as we're waiting uh
essentially the whole neighborhood came
up and got into elevated positions
around us because it was probably a good
hour I want to say I mean it's 2006 so
let's say 45 minutes to an hour
somewhere in there maybe it was more
than that
um and so all of a sudden they get in
their positions and light us up and so
we had a nice little gun battle there
but we'd done a little thinking of on
our own and we put some so snipers up
and some even higher positions the
higher highest we could get and looking
at the ISR which is uh like it was from
it wasn't really it was from a those
from an aircraft let's say uh and you
could look down the next day when we got
that footage in or maybe it was even
later that morning when we got back and
you could see our snipers up there see
them glowing on this kind of like
iridescent ISR feed and see them start
just taking people out from these
positions which is pretty pretty cool
but uh but yeah it was a it was a little
dicey a little Western as they say and
uh but we managed to get out we think
just two guys wounded but if we had been
able uh to go in or the Iraqis we've
been we were working with were allowed
to go in in their own country
um then we would have gotten out there
fairly quickly but as it was things got
a little dicey but uh we came out on top
is that the closest model danger that
you've been in
no there's some other ones there are
some other strange ones um and the
strangest was uh in najaf in 2004 and we
my sniper team and I showed up in this
uh to this city that was essentially a
campaign so two seven cab which is huge
army unit for those watching and
listening
um uh is in charge of this operation to
retake this city from the Jay shamati
militia which was run by muktada
al-satur for those who remember that
name from from back in the day uh so
essentially they had taken control of
the city the United States and our
allies want it back uh and so we go in
there and I think it was about two weeks
of
um like psychological operations ahead
of time really telling everybody in that
City to leave because we're coming in so
we telegraphed our intent not just our
intent we should tell us exactly what we
were going to do I think up to the exact
date like you have till this date to
leave uh because we're coming in and
we're coming in heavy
um so we showed up I think about a day
into it maybe even for right at the
beginning but it's fairly close to the
beginning so we were there for about 11
days of what then turned into a two-week
campaign to retake the city very
kinetically
um and uh so as it was day it was night
it was it was the only time that I was
really reminded of the World War II
movies I'd watched growing up with my
dad when they're just running through
these cities in in Europe and it's
daylight out and there's tanks and it's
just things are blowing up and it's just
crazy
um and that's because we had Abram's
tanks uh not the same tanks in World War
II obviously but reminiscent uh of those
movies that I saw in the rubble and all
that Bradley Fighting vehicles
um day night no breaks whatsoever we
didn't go back to a to a fob or a little
base and then go out at night like we
typically do in Special Operations uh to
take somebody off the board build up a
Target package go hit them in the middle
of the night come back to base this was
full on 11 days of pitched street
fighting Street battles
um and at one point in this thing and we
were just sort of support I just went
into the to the the head of the sniper
unit at the time and I just went into
the Battalion commander of two seven cab
and said hey we're here to support what
can we what can we do here's what we
bring to the table with our sniper
weapon capabilities and our uh we'll go
a close air support being able to do
pre-planned fires because we have these
these uh different
um uh qualifications that allow us to
talk to aircraft and do all that stuff
so so we we're value add to it and it
was just it was an incredible experience
but at one point I'm jump over and we'd
leave our snipers up like up at higher
higher ground we'd go push forward with
some other Army units go take the next
set of buildings push Jason Almighty
militia back another block then our
snipers would come down and go up here
and it was August so it was hot and so
now you have the Army Logistics train
bringing you food bringing you water
bringing you ammunition you kind of get
saturated again and then you go forward
again so it was 11 days of that but at
one point we jump over this wall and it
was me and three other guys and we jump
over this wall and we're in this little
Courtyard and they're both sides are
sending mortars I think at least the
other side for sure you'll remember it
since 2004 or but uh we're in this
little Courtyard and we look at each
other like can you believe we're in the
middle of this thing because up to that
point we just done middle of the night
type Ops and stacking the deck in our
favor and now we're in this battle with
these guys that are essentially you know
similar weapons to us uh during the day
anyway at night we have the night vision
and all that sort of thing but today you
know they've got AKs and we've got m4s
and you know up anyway so we jump in
this Courtyard and we look at each other
like this is crazy we talk about it for
a second and then we hop over this wall
when the last guy hits a mortar lands
exactly where we were standing not 30
seconds earlier like right in the middle
and it was kind of like oh this is fate
if something had happened at some point
during that day to just delay Us by 30
seconds we would have been standing in
that place so there are a couple times
over my time in uniform where I so
thought about fate because it uh allows
you then as a leader especially to focus
on the mission focus on the task at hand
do your job and realize hey there are
these things that you just can't control
like being in that courtyard with that
mortar Landing right right in between
you guys if we were 30 seconds later
that day crazy what do you do if you've
got a very intense High Velocity kinetic
fire fight going on for 11 days because
you can't continue to operate for 11
days or else you're going to start to
make errors presumably that are so
catastrophic that people start to get
killed on your own side etc etc so
during 11 days what do you do to find
some time you've got to grab 30 minutes
at some point presumably what happens
yeah you spill it up your your group and
a couple guys maybe you'll go back maybe
one I'll grab 30 minutes of sleep and
then come back uh in these buildings you
just try to get as deep into the
building as you can where it's a little
uh less hot uh because these buildings
have really thick walls uh memory serves
and we go back in there and find kind of
the place that was one safer than closer
to the outside walls or Windows
um and then grab 30 minutes of sleep and
then you're back at it so it was like
that but nobody wanted to sleep
everybody wanted to be fighting because
this is what we signed up to do you want
to be there doing the job figuring
things out because the enemy is adapting
to you you're adapting to the enemy you
can see them removing parts of buildings
like small little holes where they were
to take their shots and then put that
stuff back uh in place and so we started
doing that sort of thing too a couple
rooms deep though so you could uh have a
little more protection from the outside
and it's a little harder to see in if
you have a window up here at the at the
front well you don't want to be shooting
from this room maybe you move back into
this other room and put a little
loophole on the wall there so you can
still shoot out but from somebody
looking in just the Shadows make it look
like it's unoccupied so you're doing all
these things to adapt to the enemy the
enemy is adapting to you and that's
typically what Warfare is and whoever is
going to do that faster than their
opponent uh oftentimes ends up on top
from a storytelling perspective it
sounds
maybe not romantic but at least heroic
and
sanitized and and civilized in some
regards like even you know the most
brutal there was a mortar and it landed
next to us and we could have been killed
and legs blown off and all this sort of
stuff
what's the reality of your emotions and
the sense that you have inside when
you're going through this because you
know we get to observe uh a version in
our own minds if we read your books or a
version on a television screen if we get
to watch a movie or a series or
something like the terminalist
but the actual felt sense of being
somebody even somebody that's been
trained even somebody that's you know
gone through this and this is what they
want to do and this is what they've
chosen to do and this is what they're
trying to do
what's that actually like when you're on
the ground yeah it's interesting because
you can do all the right things like if
we were in a room right now uh air
conditioned nice had some water out and
we're we're going through a scenario
maybe with a group maybe not but just
what would you do in this type of a
scenario thing
um and you could make all the right
decisions in this air-conditioned or
space uh with all the experience that
you have all the books that you've read
um and you could do those things and the
instructor could say yep that looks
great maybe you tweak this here maybe
not whatever okay you could do perfect
in that scenario you did the exact same
thing out on the battlefield and it
could be catastrophic just because the
enemy gets a vote and things change so
quickly and there is that Murphy's law
that luck that fate all of those other
things involved that aren't involved
that aren't in play back in this
air-conditioned space when you're
learning or teaching or evolving so uh
back in a classroom I mean so uh so it's
so it's different so when you're out on
the battlefield all those right
political right things are still in play
but now there's some other things in
play also that weren't in play when
you're in that air-conditioned room in
training and for me the sense of as a
leader I remember this distinctly
because I didn't expect it ahead of time
and it was a sense of relief and I
talked about my first book and about a
paragraph maybe two in that first novel
and I've had a lot of people reach out
and tell me that that paragraph in
particular meant so much to them because
they hadn't really been able to
conceptualize or articulate uh some of
how they felt by doing the job downrange
and by reading those paragraphs it made
it okay then you were told what the
sense is that you go through in those
paragraphs so it's about the relief it's
about not about knowing that yeah you
think you can do the job and you've
that's what your job is in the military
is to prepare for war
um it's not necessarily to go to war
it's to go if you called but your job
every single day for every single second
you're in the military is to be prepared
for war and to prepare yourself off even
better than you were prepared the day
before make yourself a better operator
better leader today than you were
yesterday
um so uh so but you still don't really
know until you get out there and doing
bullets are whizzing by and you have to
prioritize things because there's so
much going on
um and so for me it was a sense of
relief it was like I've been thinking
about this my whole life essentially
I've been training for it my whole life
both physically and uh and mentally by
pushing myself and then intellectually
by studying Warfare
um so for me being in that scenario in
particular in the Joff in 2004 it was
like okay this was a this was a test and
it was a relief
that I could do it
um so anyway yeah that was not one that
I was expecting to feel but it's one
that I wove into the novel in that
particular uh paragraph because it it
made sense and that's what I talk about
by uh by being so personal was uh was in
that respect because I wouldn't really
uh talked about it with anybody talked
about that in particular with anybody
unless it made sense to flow into this
storyline for my protagonist James Reese
so it's uh so in that sense it's
therapeutic as well but yeah it's a
sense of relief of being tested and and
doing okay coming on the other side okay
for your guys
I wrote a story in a newsletter recently
that I think is very similar to what
you're talking about but from a civilian
perspective so I'll read it to you now I
recently got to speak to a friend who
I've been curious about for a long time
he went through a difficult period many
years ago even though he's Beyond it now
he came very close to losing everything
financially reputationally
psychologically I asked him how he dealt
with the darkest time that he'd ever
faced he told me that he'd had a concern
in the back of his mind throughout his
entire life he was always worried that
deep down he might be a coward that
secretly he might not be the strong
capable person he thought he was that
when the rubber met the road he wouldn't
be able to stand up and face whatever
the world threw at him see many of the
challenges that we face in life are
largely under our control we choose the
jobs that we apply for the house we try
to afford the partner we seduce the
weight we lift these things can still be
hard it can be tough challenging
sometimes unbearably difficult but it
was us that chose the flavor of that
difficulty so what happens when
absolutely everything comes crashing
down the single worst possible scenario
that you can imagine well you get to see
what you're made of what you're
genuinely made of when all of your
forces are marshaled to a single
Challenge and he said that he'd had
faith in himself but he'd never been
pushed hard enough to prove that his
faith was justified and this is the
quote that still makes the hairs on the
back of my next stand up he says I could
always hear my best self clearing his
throat in the room next door
you never knew if this self was able to
come in when needed and it turns out
that he did I love the quote and I love
this story because I think many of us
are uncertain about just how capable we
are maybe a couple of times in your life
all hell will break loose and your best
self will have to stop his coughing and
come say hello
interesting no I love it I love it the
only difference is that like I I felt I
know a lot of the guys feel supremely uh
I guess confidence the wrong word but
it's uh I mean you feel like you know
you can do it but you haven't done it
yet type of a thing and even the other
operations that I've done up until that
point uh we'd stack the odds in our
favor so it's like you're going in
you're with the A Team you're going into
the Super Bowl with all this experience
now uh of doing that particular type of
an operation uh you put yourself on the
enemy shoes figured out how they're
going to adapt to you after having seen
you do this mission in X configuration y
configuration whatever it might be how
they would have adapted and you adapt
accordingly
um so to be thrown into that old like
World War II scenario where there was it
was just Insanity for 11 days
um so that that was that was I mean it
sounds weird to say cool
um but it was it was um that's what we
had we trained up to do that to be
tested and that was a I mean it was a
test because that's not exactly what
we've been trained up to do because
we've been trained up look at those kind
of operations where you're stacking the
deck in your favor
um and now we're out there with the
enemy in the broad Daylights to reach
the street
um and all that so it's uh so you still
feel like you you you know you can pull
it off but if you haven't been in it
there's still that little it's not like
you doubt it like you're not doubting
yourself at all but if you haven't done
it it's not doubt it's just like a okay
fine now I got to run close that Loop
yeah I'm running it all the time on my
own on the track or something like that
and you're somebody's there with the
stopwatch bam you know you're hitting it
you know you're hitting you know you're
hitting it and then but you haven't run
it in the Olympics yet against these
other people at the same same track same
track same distance uh weather
conditions even
um but you haven't run it then under
those like same thing boxing or on the
mat like some great guys like just can't
do it in the ring in the Octagon same
thing boxing it's a different deal in
that ring when the crowd is yelling at
you
um there's just something different
about it so you might be great just
sparring and doing all your normal
things that your local boxing gym or a
club or whatever or whatever it is but
then you get in that ring and it's
different when there's people there like
that sort of a thing like you know you
can do it but because you've done it but
you haven't done it in this scenario yet
type of a thing so anyway it was it was
a relief to I guess uh have been tested
and for lack of a better phrase to not
be found wanting I guess damn right what
about the fact that you not only were a
sniper but then were leading a sniper
team I think
it's probably right in saying that the
sniper position is the most romanticized
kind of Highly mysterious you like the
wizard of the of the battlefield in a
way what is it that people don't
understand or what what do people get
wrong when they think about the
lifestyle the role of a sniper and what
are some of the more sort of brutal
realities of what you actually end up
facing and doing during an operation
yeah that's good that's a great question
when I haven't been asked before and I
don't know if I've really thought about
it in those terms
um but I'll think about it right now
um a lot of it it was based on leading
up to September 11th uh like movies that
we'd seen about Vietnam or about snipers
from Vietnam essentially alone maybe
with a spotter crawling through the
jungle to get to this position to wait
for an NVA element to walk through and
then find the office MBA uh North
Vietnamese Army uh and I come down the
Ho Chi Minh trail and then find that
officer and find that radio man like
that sort of a thing
or is it an advanced element is it a
trap they just that sort of a thing so I
think the the people thinking about how
alone you are is probably the part
that's misunderstood the most especially
today and this is my experience like
they're probably other snipers that have
completely other experience you know
different experience than I do but when
we went out it was as a team it wasn't
just the one guy the two guys going in
position you brought a heavy weapon
Gunner with you so somebody with a
machine gun or two even better in case
you're compromised and what a medic yep
and a communicator so you went out as a
team so that you could at least fend uh
uh defend yourself a little bit if
you're compromised what you call in qrf
so a quick reaction force that's ready
to come come get you so I think that's
probably the most misunderstood part is
people think of a sniper as a loan and
you do our training alone a lot uh in
the school you have a sniper or buddy
with you you switch off being a spotter
for meaning you're looking through the
glass and calling the shots and then you
switch off and and but that's really
based on the old Vietnam experience and
we really we really just that was the
only experience that we had up until
September 11th and then we moved to
Afghanistan moved into Iraq a little bit
later and we've really start to evolve
these tactics techniques and procedures
when it comes to sniping a lot of time
you're in support of a ground element
that's moving in or somebody that's
coming in ground and air and you're just
there in a supporting position
um to for to contain what we call
squirters they're leaving the target so
there's a lot of different things that
you can do as a as a sniper so I think
that's probably the most misunderstood
is that you just go off alone with your
rifle and that's that's not exactly how
that wasn't exactly my experience anyway
you're in a window by yourself maybe but
you have a spotter here or at another
another window somebody's on another
level somebody's out the back door you
got your heavy weapon Gunner there you
got support
um so so you're you're alone in a sense
but no more alone than you are as an 18
year old Marine who's told to hold a
corner with your uh you know M4 and just
you're that person with that rifle
making you're the last decision maker
and that chain that starts with the
president of the United States and comes
all the way down you're that last
decision maker with your finger on the
trigger right there on that street
corner so and uh so in that respect
you're just as alone as that 18 year old
kid you're just you just maybe have a
little more training does it feel like a
lot of pressure to have an entire group
of people who are all there to support
one person's performance so to speak
everybody's contributing to it and the
heavy gunner is there in case you get
spotted but the reason that you're
risking being spotted is presumably
because you have some special leverage
you are a very unique tool that is in a
very unique position that can give a
type of
[Music]
um
assistance that is very difficult to get
outside of that does that apply more and
more pressure especially when you're on
the battlefield there's mortal danger
that's cetera I mean just in the sense
that you're worried about letting your
guys down that you're worried about
letting them down by making out making a
mistake maybe but you're really so
focused on that mission that that's not
an overriding concern that once again
this is just all all personal
um so it wasn't overriding as in in that
respect
um and oftentimes you'll switch through
because so many guys are trained up as
snipers so you'll switch through these
positions uh because you can't be there
on the glass all day or whatever it is
or even all night with uh whatever night
vision type of a system that you're
using what was the longest time that you
think that you set up watching
probably one of the one of the nights
when nothing happens
um so probably a few hours I can't
remember right now but I think we'd
switch off every couple hours especially
with a team like that let's say four
five six guys I think we wouldn't be on
for more than an hour or two
um how much truth is that in the sniper
position being held rolling over taking
a dump into a tupperware that the guy
next to you has to clean up and all of
that stuff like how much truth's in that
because it seems like you're talking
about a period of time that's well easy
enough to hold a dump in for yeah yeah
we wouldn't go out for too long I mean
you'd oftentimes make plans to stay out
longer and just like you're walking
through your own neighborhood I mean you
can tell when something's off there's
like hey something's different today I
don't know what it is and you could
sense when people would feel that uh in
the daytime typically uh and people will
be taking their kids wherever they're
taking them and there's normal traffic
and then all of a sudden something
shifts and why does it shift because
they notice that something was different
different uh not sure what it is I mean
you you can go back and think and like I
have no idea like sometimes it's just a
sense and then they take a second look
at that house they're like oh oh so and
so didn't come out today usually at this
time of day they're hanging up laundry
whatever it is something that you can't
even figure out ahead of time you
wouldn't know ahead of time but
something that changed just enough
especially when you're in a place like
ramadi or missoul or someplace like do
you um do you become if you've been
spotting for a good amount of time if
you've been watching a particular
neighborhood or a number of streets and
a number of individuals that come and go
do you become intimately familiar with
them do you name them do you imagine
what their lives are like at all do you
sort of solidify them someone else might
have a different experience but uh but I
did not have that that experience uh
because I don't think I saw the same
people often it was like a city uh with
all the things going on so there's a lot
a lot going on uh it's not like for me
anyway uh I'm sure other people have a
different experience of being looking at
a remote Village for a long time and
really getting to know people like can
see that but my experience was really in
the cities
um which also meant it was pretty
Dynamic and people would notice that uh
that something was off on this house or
this building and uh especially after
two days-ish or something like that then
you're coming you're coming out
um and uh before before they get the
upper hand
um so it's uh yes but it was but it was
but it's all it's a thinking man's game
and that's what I'm in my last in in the
blood that's what I wanted to write a
sniper-centric novel last time without
that uh scene of two snipers on opposite
hillsides or buildings that are looking
for each other and then they're looking
and then they find each other at the
last second and one guy shoots and it
goes through the other guy's scope just
before he can shoot or you know that
scene that we've seen in a bunch of
movies and books up to this point so I
thought how do you do a sniper Centric
novel without that scene and that was
the thinking man's part of it like how
do you out think this other sniper
um and I just wanted that was the that
was the fun part for me of writing that
book but it's similar to what you're
what we're talking about right here is
uh is out thinking the enemy
um and uh and that you're doing that on
the battlefield and that's what I'm
doing on the on the page or in the pages
of these books
you're a guy who's been through
selection who's been in kinetic Warfare
nearly been hit by mortars being in cars
that have been attacked by machine guns
how does that compare to being in the
middle of a cancellation Fury or when
the terminalist hits Amazon Prime
like people that weren't too excited
about it like uh The Daily Beast uh I
guess it was to be expected you know
it's uh you can't expect everyone's
gonna love it uh especially certain
segments that might already have it out
for maybe your lead star or uh the
subject matter in particular or have
read one of the books and already hate
you or have looked at your Instagram and
uh and I already hate you so you know
that's just how it goes these days and
that's okay
um you know that's uh there is a large
segment of the population who it does
resonate with thank goodness and uh and
Amazon has all those numbers though
they'll never share them and that's why
we have a spin-off and
yeah many sequels yeah the terminal list
is an attempt to valorize the same toxic
tenor of military culture a culture
that's long protected rather than
prosecuted those who engage in immoral
and illegal Behavior this valorization
of vigilantism is a rising tide in pop
culture to me vigilantism doesn't seem
like a rising tide I think back to
movies like The Punisher that I think's
been me remade at least two or three
times now I think about John Wick
perhaps which is kind of like I mean
that's pure vigilantism like don't
with this dog but um I I don't think
that that is the case and I think that
we have seen a Resurgence of relatively
uncomplicated not simple but on
complicated storylines where the good
guys are the good guys and the bad guys
are the bad guys top gun Maverick last
year I think one of the highest grossing
movies if not the highest grossing movie
of the year unbelievable to watch even
other things like bullet train which was
complex but also it wasn't subversive in
uh trying to get across some strange
kind of political commentary
um so yeah man me and my housemate
absolutely loved it he stayed up uh he
he completely me we watched the
first couple of episodes and then he
stayed up all night and completed the
season woke up the next day and was like
dude you've got to you need to stay up
and watch it and I thought well we would
this was a nice thing and now I feel
betrayed because you've stayed up all
night and watched it um but yeah you
know I I think you're right for as long
as the market has desire for this stuff
I'm sure people have got problems with
succession I'm sure that there's some
tropes in succession and and the
reinforcement of
White City attorney normative
patriarchal capitalism or something
but the season and the series is
absolutely fantastic and for as
long as it's good people are going to
watch it and you're not going to be able
to shame people out of watching
something entertaining and you're also
not going to be able to guilt people
into watching something that's
that that's it and I mean death wish in
the 70s with Charles Bronson I mean
these things have been around for for
quite some time and uh you know it's
really about for us it was all about
telling a story uh like it is for me in
the novels I don't look at Amazon
reviews and say oh look at this person
didn't like this in the last book I'm
gonna have to change this or I wonder if
I'm gonna alienating audience and and
never it was 100 only about the story
you have to honor that story I never
think about an audience I never think
about a Critic I never think about a
comment it's all about the story that's
what I have to do because people are
trusting me with this time they're never
getting back that's not something I take
extremely seriously so every part of me
my heart and soul has to go into every
single word but it has to be about the
story and in every single meeting we had
with Chris and Antoine Fuqua and the
whole executive production team uh Chris
always would remind us that we're making
this we're not making this for critics
we're making it for this person who went
to Iraq and Afghanistan over the last 20
years so when they sit on that couch and
crack a beer and turn this thing on they
at least know that we put in the effort
to make something for them that was
rooted in the realities of my Modern
Warfare that explored the mindset of a
modern day warrior with this skill set
who now has nothing left to lose so
we're making it for you we're not making
it for The Daily Beast that's for sure
um and it's uh and some of those critics
like some of the ones that uh that you
read and and uh the way you just
described looking at succession or
something like that it's gosh that's a
what a horrible way to go through life
it seems there's plenty of other things
you could read if this isn't yours if
this isn't the thing that's speaking to
you uh we live in a time where there's
so much but let's just say it was just
books and movies uh there are plenty
other ones out there why would you waste
time just trying to uh ruin someone
else's day or to apply a filter on a
show that a lot of people are enjoying
but you want to just speak for
themselves I think how nasty it is and
it just says something about you I think
rather than oh it's subjective guess
what it's art art is subjective uh Move
Along you'll live a much happier life
but that's just how it goes these days
what
would have been an easier way for you to
compromise the screen adaptation for
instance what was some of the decisions
that that keeping it in were always
going to cause problems uh and there is
I'm sure there wasn't a discussion
because you wanted to stay true and it
seems like Chris was also on board with
with this also being super super aligned
um but what were some of the things that
you think this would have gotten rid of
most of the criticism but also
compromised the show oh if we got rid of
most of the criticism it would be awful
um
so we never really thought about that I
can't really you know I can't I can't
think of a disembowling maybe the
disemboweling with a tomahawk ax perhaps
I didn't think they were that upset with
that uh but Amazon was nervous about it
that's for sure
um and it was one of those ones where we
had the scripts go up to the top of
Amazon and they come back down with
notes and this is a very collaborative
process whereas the novels just me 100
creative control no guidance or my agent
they never even hint at unencumbered
yeah it's 100 me which is great because
if it doesn't work I have only one
person to blame that is a hundred
percent my yeah exactly now the other
side of the house here with
screenwriting this is a very
collaborative team oriented process
um so just like in anything where
politics are involved in by politics I
mean interpersonal relationship type
politics when you're when uh when you're
trying to create something special but
uh everybody wants wants that to be the
end goal but other everybody's bringing
their past experience to it everybody's
bringing something different which can
be wonderful but I can also see when you
hear these stories about writer's rooms
devolving into chaos or things just
going off the rails on set or whatever
it might be I can see how that can
happen we got very very lucky here but
very collaborative so once you get the
outline for the scripts done and then
you get the scripts done then they go up
to the top of Amazon and then they come
back down with notes and one of those
notes was about the uh disemboweling
scene and there were some I guess the
best way to put some concerns uh that uh
that might be a little little much and
we lose the audience
um so that was one we we fought for and
to Amazon's credit they went with us
they went with us on I think everything
that we wanted
um every time something came up it was a
little contentious they sided with us
and kind of went all right you know
we're gonna trust you and for a penny in
for a pound we'd say yeah but luckily we
had Chris and we had Antoine and we had
the showrunner and so all of us as a as
a team would very thoughtfully discuss
us how we were going to deal with this
and so we filmed it uh I think Amazon
thought that we're just going to let
them film it and uh we're not we're
never going to let them put it in uh and
then it ends up being the shot that's on
every billboard in La when it launches
is Chris Pratt holding that Tomahawk
right like that shot from the side and
yeah so if we didn't have that in there
we probably would have lost a lot of the
core audience that were fans of the book
because enough has to change anyway
where uh people that are going to get
upset about changes they're going to get
upset anyway but if you lose a couple of
these scenes you're gonna really lose
the people that are even understanding
of the fact that there are going to be
changes so uh so a few of those things
like that had to really had to be in
there
um and were important to keep in there
so so that was one of them uh there was
an ending I think we talked about it on
the podcast we did a terminal this
podcast so I think we talk about it on
there but there was another ending that
uh that Amazon was fond of and it's just
wasn't going to work
we were going to lose everybody we'd
taken along this ride insufficiently
satisfying yeah yeah and uh so once
again they they went along with we did
film two endings will that ever be
released in a DVD thing I don't think so
I don't think so the other one's not
good
[Laughter]
and I don't think we really put our
heart and soul into that one I think
everybody involved knew that Chris
turned up and half-assed it that day it
wasn't even yeah it's not even he's not
even in it actually in that one scene
um but uh yeah I think we would have
really lost everybody if but once again
Amazon amazing went with us and we
pulled it off even though it's different
than the book the whole what was really
important to Chris and Antoine and me
and the showrunner was to stay true to
the spirit of the novel knowing we have
eight hours to tell this it's a team
process you have budgets uh you have set
pieces you have travel restrictions
there's all these things that aren't in
a novel I can do anything I want in a
novel but yeah all those other things
are at play in a script
um a lot of rules uh for screenwriting
which uh if they exist for writing a
thriller I don't know them because I'm
just doing what I love to do and telling
a story
um but in screenwriting There Are Rules
so we ended up pulling it off and Amazon
went with us on every single one of
those um contentious decisions and uh
and it uh it and it paid off him
what is a daily routine a morning
routine a daily routine like for you
when you are deep in the writing process
well I just get more tired because I'm
staying up later and later but I still
have to get up to get the kids to school
and get everybody fed and it's just like
any other parent out there that's like
trying to get their kids to school and
saying where's your backpack did you
where's your violation of violin day
like all those things get in the car
we're late
um so all those things are at play as
well so once that chaos has subsided
then dive in to the work and for me it's
all about uninterrupted time
uninterrupted time
um and uh it has to I don't need a great
view I just need quiet quiet
uninterrupted time so each of the novels
I've written in a different place the
first one was off our little office off
our bedroom rental in Coronado
California during my last year in the
SEAL Teams between about 10 at night and
three in the morning because that's the
only time that it was semi quiet in our
household with three kids dog wife and
all the all the rest
um and this one before this well two
before this I went to the local library
and was using one of those little study
rooms that they have there but you can
only stay in them for like two hours if
someone else is waiting so as soon as
high school got out I get bumped out for
kids working on history projects and
that sort of thing but that worked for a
little bit and then I rented airbnbs for
the last one for In The Blood and that
was fantastic found a little cabin not
too far away and I thought I was going
to do it for this last book for only the
dead and then I got up there and it's
about a mile from our house I can
actually see the house from this little
cabin and I just didn't feel right
didn't feel right and I was like I was
realizing our kids are uh 17 15 and 12
and I realized that I was gonna miss the
interruptions when they were gone so I
decided to embrace the interruptions
which probably pushed my uh my this
writing process about two months maybe
two and a half months to the right but I
realized that hey this is just how it's
going to be and I'm going to miss these
interruptions when they're gone so it's
just what life is like right now and
that's okay so I wrote it up the house
and just tried to ride it when the kids
were at school and then I pulled some
some really late nights uh and pulled a
couple all-nighters which are getting
harder to do the older I get uh for
Savage son a few books back no no
problem no problem pulling all nighters
this one oh yeah you're feeling it
brutal yeah I'm feeling it now but uh
eventually I will get a much more
disciplined approach but right now from
the beginning it's felt like an
entrepreneurial type of Adventure
meaning I have to I'm the CEO I'm the
CFO I'm the CMO I'm the creative I'm the
social media manager I'm all of those
things
um but and I have to also say yes to to
everything because people have to know
that whatever this widget is if you're
an entrepreneur you have this you've
created this thing people have to know
that it exists so what do you have to do
what are the supporting efforts to this
product that are going to allow you to
get this out in the world and allow you
to continue to do what you do in my case
that's writing that's what I love that's
my passion my mission is taking care of
my family writing is the passion they
come together and for my purpose going
forward
um but I didn't realize I thought you
could kind of just go to a cabin in the
mountains right send it to New York
maybe do an interview and then start
your next book that was totally not it
especially today you could have gotten
away with that in 1985 if you were one
of the last names that we all know like
King uh something or DeMille or morale
or one of these last names Clancy from
back in the day but today it's different
there are so many more platforms that
you can take advantage of and there sure
are uh outliers of course but if you're
just gonna do the work and get in there
and get dirty and figure this thing out
well now you can take advantage of
YouTube and Instagram and Facebook and
Twitter and a webpage and a podcast and
do all these other things that support
your main effort of the book and still
that product that book has to be the
best that it can possibly be but then
everything else also has to be on that
same level so that podcast has to be the
best that it can possibly be any blog
entry any post on Instagram
um because all those things people are
trusting you with that time that we
talked about earlier not just with the
book whether it's an audiobook or
they're actually or reading it but just
scrolling through and stopping on your
Instagram post and reading a little
history or whatever it might be on there
you have to add value to people's lives
throughout the year and then there's
this connection piece that wasn't
available in 1975 85 95 even really
2005. uh really after that it's when
things started to change and where it
became important to know the person
behind the product in this case a book
that wasn't really as important 30 years
prior because you couldn't you didn't
really know what was behind that book or
that movie or whatever else well now now
people want to know and uh that
authenticity piece is so important today
to everyone uh overused term but it's
really there's not a better one
um and so for me that authenticity piece
it's it's as it's part of the novel but
it's also this it's us talking and you
it'd be tough to not be you today and I
know people try but their lives must be
miserable uh because if you're not you
and you're active on social channels
eventually it'll come out correct and uh
and it's going to be awful to try to do
that but but if you don't and you're
just open and honest people respect that
and you have a product that is top tier
and everything else you're doing is also
top tier that supports that product
anyway that's how I looked at it
how do you avoid the main thing not
being the main thing anymore there's
lots of these other ways that you get
pulled you've got to do the podcast and
the interviews and oh there's a
screenplay and I've got this meeting and
there'll be a zoom call and we've got to
make sure and there's emails and all the
rest of it and yet the highest point of
Leverage that you need to get done is to
put words down onto paper how do you
avoid distraction from the main thing
and what is your process for staying
motivated and disciplined when it comes
to writing so that's real that's really
what I'm working on right now is I have
been working on it since the beginning
but really more so over the last year
it's become unsustainable to keep the
pace up that I've kept that I've been on
since the beginning and there are more
projects out there with this origin
story with the next book coming out with
Chris Pratt so those two separate series
uh writing for those I'll write the
finale episodes on both those this time
around Rapunzel's down on it because of
the writer strike right now but there's
and there's other projects out there in
the works as well have a non-fiction
book come coming out on Beirut the 1983
Beirut Barracks bombing there's the pot
there's all those things
um and so there really is uh I mean you
are being pulled in a lot of different
directions so I'm gonna have to get at
this stage turn from the uh like I
started the computer company my garage
in 1976 77 uh into like a more into the
in a little in office space outside the
garage type of a thing what does your
what does your team look like at the
moment it was me only from the beginning
um but now over the last few months now
I have not just one literary agent but I
think there's six different agents now
each one has a different specialty which
is fantastic now there's an
entertainment attorney that overlooks
all of that kind of the umbrella uh over
all of those different uh different
agents there's that there's a manager to
make sure business manager but not the
kind that goes out and looks for things
but makes sure that you're keeping out
of trouble with the IRS so that's oh I
could never my brain does not work that
way so that is totally outsourced
because now you have merch in 50
different states 40 different countries
each one of those States changes their
tax laws by the year
um so yeah so that's uh so there's that
by publisher uh Emily Bessler amazing
has been incredible from the very
beginning at Simon and Schuster my
publicist David Brown uh he's been with
me from the beginning as well my agent
Alexander machinist literary side of the
house she's like the umbrella agent over
all the other ones kind of
um so the team's I know an assistant now
who schedules everything because I was
just spending I mean Untold hours just
trying to keep these different
interviews straight and different
appointments straight and all that stuff
and that was taking away time that
wasn't going into the book so uh so this
is the year to kind of figure all that
out but I think now that's that's the
team that's the team and really their
Ironclad who does the podcast production
and does my book trailer videos and
deals with uh any business side of the
house with merch sure whatever else like
it's Outsourcing all those things
trusting that uh maybe some of it might
not be done exactly the way you want it
and that's that's the price that you pay
uh for being able to dive all into the
book is something uh something else
something smaller not being exactly the
way you would like it but it's okay
you're probably the only one that's
going to notice uh so but for me it's
like the Instagram thing is still me
Twitter is still me all those because
it's such an important connection
um that I have with this readership
because
you know leading up to the third novel I
was kind of hoping that Chris Pratt
would tweet or put something on
Instagram about the show I was kind of
hoping that Joe Rogan would invite me on
I would hoping that because I've known
him for a while so when the Tucker would
invite me on
um but it didn't happen now I'm so
thankful that none of those guys asked
me on until that third book hit the New
York Times list and then the first two
bumped on after that because now even in
my mind one one yeah you don't have to
worry about people saying oh must be
nice the only reason you do this is
because you got on Rogan or whatever
else like that's off and and also for me
saying well wow geez could I have done
this without going on Rogan could I have
done this without you that's not even a
part of my that's not even part of my
calculus not taking up any bandwidth in
my head because it was all Grassroots
and it was all people taking a risk on
me as a new author and telling a friend
at work or telling uh the buddy on
social media or telling a family member
who in tour and told another family
member so that made it so Grassroots and
so powerful from a foundational
standpoint Point
um so now I'm thankful that Chris didn't
say anything until after that that Rogan
didn't ask me until after that and that
Tucker didn't have me on until after
that because those were the three that
in the lead up I was kind of like oh man
it'd be really nice if one of those
three have two of them if all three
happened uh but none of them did until
after the New York Times and you still
made it work yeah there's um I remember
hearing about Eddie Hearn who is a
boxing promoter uh from the UK and he
manages a ton of huge huge fights and
his father was very successful in boxing
promotion two and they were talking
about the challenges that Eddie had been
through as a byproduct of his father's
success and he'd grown up with wealth
and and stuff which you know is both
positive and negative and one of the
things that Eddie said was he almost
resented his father's success in a way
because he would never be able to prove
whether or not he could have done it
without him and that's a big mirror I
think to the scenario that you're
encountering another thing that I've
been thinking about a lot over the last
two weeks uh Bill Perkins guy who wrote
die with zero it's a very short book
about
um how to use money to enjoy life as
opposed to saving indefinitely it's
fantastic I highly highly recommend it
it's three hours I would die with zero
uh he's also been on the show so I'll
send you a link to listen to that
episode
um
he I spent a good bit of time with him
he has a holiday home here in Austin and
uh I've been wake surfing with him four
times since he's been on the show in the
last 10 days so I've got really good at
wake surfing but I've also got to spend
a good bit of time with him and one of
the things that I realized is
there's lots of content on the internet
about how to become rich and almost no
content on the internet about how to be
rich there's lots of content on the
internet about how to become successful
and almost no content about how to be
successful most people are on the come
up toward getting toward the size of a
jacket one millionth of the size of a
jack car right
once you're there
all of the lessons do I need an
assistant do I need two do I need a
personal do I need an executive what
about a manager do I need a chief of
staff should I get a an operations
manager first or do I need a chief of
operations what about the chief of staff
how do they work with the age and you
know it's a problem that the cohort who
has this this issue is so small that
it's not surprising because the
incentives for writing this sort of
stuff and creating this content online
is to appeal to a wider audience how
many people have the problem of trying
to juggle multiple fiction and
non-fiction bestsellers with an Amazon
Prime deal right it's a it's a pretty
small cohort but
that doesn't make it any smaller of a
problem and you don't have anybody there
to try and teach you so spending a good
bit of time with Bill somebody who is
incredibly wealthy very successful and
and uses it as far as I can see
uh in a very smart way and looking at
his systems how dialed in all of the
things that he has in his life he's got
an EA he's EA's got a PA he's got a
person that does his diet and nutrition
his chef speaks to the nutritionist and
then Cooks his meals based on what that
is the assistant makes sure that his
schedule is done and the driver makes
sure he's there on time and the blah
blah like everything is dialed in and he
calls them neuron cycles and he protects
his neuron Cycles as much as possible he
says for him it's making money for you
it would be writing great words
I make money with my mind the more
neuron cycles that I take up thinking I
haven't put Petrol in the car or have we
got milk for the for coffee in the
morning all of those things are taking
away from my highest point of Leverage
and yet like
having that conversation online opens
you up to so much cynicism around people
saying you know what a luxurious
Bourgeois
must be nice yeah exactly
the bottom line is that there are people
out there who have these systems in
place and I've started to hang about
with them and to see that is just really
inspiring to see how high the ladder can
go just how good the efficiency can get
how much can be outsourced how much can
be delegated and it's cool to see that
you're beginning to uh turn pro in
Stephen pressfield language I suppose to
get to that level exactly and it's uh it
I've just started down that path to
figure out how to become more effective
and efficient which means you have to
let go and you have to trust all those
people also uh to make sure hey they got
the right date on the calendar in the
right time something as easy as that and
to know that you don't have to double
check or go back in your emails just to
confirm because you're like wait that
didn't sound quite right it has to be
all the way off you never have to have
that thought and that thought has to go
into whatever that profession is uh for
me writing um so so I mean there are
definitely some tweaks that need to
happen but I'm starting down that path
and then uh then eventually I'll have to
add sleep nutrition
um
that is back on my list because those
fell to the bottom of my priority list
uh because you're doing all those other
other things and this is the time to to
do it this is what I love uh I've always
wanted to write since I was a little kid
so I know that that right now is is my
time to do that but also it's time to
introduce some more of those
efficiencies so that I can take that
breath because right now it's just
family and work that's it
um and uh so I can need to introduce
some more of that uh uh some of those
efficiencies in there so that I can
um operate at Optimal Performance I
guess get the good the right fuel in
there I've seen it I've seen I've seen
people now first-hand operating at
unbelievably high levels
very effectively and efficiently in
enjoying life because of how much
they've been able to Outsource it now
you know the bottom line is that much of
this is a function of money that if you
have the capital to be able to spend
then you can afford the the bits that
this gets put together but also it's a
function of being able to relinquish
control being able to delegate being
prepared to do that being able to put
Faith in other people to allow them to
learn through failure uh to to pay the
price the existential like oh I missed
that meeting oh the it's because
they put the meeting on for the wrong
day or they didn't check the email or
whatever like those are just prices that
you're going to have to pay so one of
the other things that I imagine is a big
chunk of your time must be research for
the story lines uh for inspiration for
the book and presumably not everything
can be inspired by personal experience
so what does the research process look
like for this well a lot of them it
shifted with covert because I couldn't
go anywhere
um my initial thought out of the gate
was that I would at least go to to one
color at one trip maybe multiple
countries but one trip focused on
research for a novel
um so for the first book I'd been to
Iraq been to Afghanistan I chose places
in the United States that I'd already
been so I wouldn't have to travel to
them to do that that research so that
was the first one second one now I'm out
of the military uh start that second one
about a month after I'm out of the
military and I fly to Mozambique because
I know that this is going to be a very
important part of the storyline I don't
see I don't have any money to be flying
to Mozambique or doing any of these
things but I thought of that John
Grisham story about he wrote A Time to
Kill first and he couldn't give that
book away and then he writes the firm
and we've had a John Grisham novel every
year in some years two John Christian
novels every year since but I always
thought of like what if he'd stopped
what if he'd stop and not written The
Firm then he'd probably just now be
retiring from some law practice that
he'd hated and he'd always it would have
wasted wasted some sort of bandwidth
thinking about what could have been or
maybe I should have written another book
uh but he did and and he uh from all uh
indicate occasions he loves writing and
loves the life that he is he has built
so I always thought about that so hence
my reason for being on a plane to
Mozambique without any means to do so
um and so that was fantastic putting
boots on the ground I learned so much
over there talking to the professional
hunters and The Trackers and talking to
them about the politics in their country
and Chinese influence both legal and
illegal mining operations just all these
poaching uh all these things that I
incorporated into the storyline uh so
much so that I went back uh before that
was published to South Africa I did a
research for my third novel and a little
bit for the one that I was just
finishing up I also went to kamchaka
Peninsula Russia for that third novel
for Savage sun because once again that
was going to be a very important part of
the storyline that I didn't want to just
get information by zooming in on Google
Earth and looking up something on
Wikipedia I wanted to go there and
really know the sights and the sounds
and the smells yeah and what are you
looking for there you're you're in this
place are you taking down notes are you
doing voice recordings are you taking
videos and photos and what are you
looking out for videos photos uh I had a
whole stack of questions in a notebook
that I had written out for the
Mozambique trip for that first one and I
had a lot of phrases that I wanted to
get translated into different dialects
so I had maybe nine I think nine
different dialects that I wanted things
translated into just in case I didn't
know which ones I'd use but just in the
off chance that I would use some of them
and I didn't want to go back like I
should have gotten that other thing
translated because now it makes more
sense to have this other you know
whatever involved so there's a lot of
that there's a lot of questions like
some basic stuff that I was going to ask
about but then once I got over there and
started talking to people then I wrote
down and took so many notes on things
that I never would have even thought to
have asked fracking this air-conditioned
room taking down notes because one thing
leads to another you get to know people
you're having some drinks you're having
a cigar you're having a shared
experience together you're learning
about their background and you would
never have thought to create a
background because this is someone real
and who's telling you a story about
their childhood or about how they got to
this place in Life or what their time
was like in the military in Africa or
whatever it might be and you wouldn't
have gotten that just by reading an
article or typing in Mozambique on the
uh in in the search bar so when I went
to kamchaka I took a lot less I had a
couple things I wanted to make sure I I
I touched on or asked about but a lot
less because I learned so much that
wasn't even in my notes but then when I
went to Russia it was very different I
thought it was going to be because I
hadn't taken the time to think about it
ahead of time but I thought that
everybody was going to be open just like
they were Mozambique everyone wanted to
talk to me about their country and the
politics and their background got to
Russia and I thought it was going to be
the same and very quickly realized that
no very everyone was very guarded and I
think that's because for most of Russian
history if someone was asking you the
types of questions that I was for a
thriller political thriller Espionage
throw it that you weren't long for this
world off to the gulag with you type of
a thing so they were just inherently
more guarded over there which was
interesting as well and also made it
into the storyline so
um so for the next one covet hit and so
everything was shut down for the the
fourth novel so I had most of my
research was online luckily it was a
domestically based storyline so I did a
lot of interviews just on Zoom or on the
phone or via email
and so so that's same thing with the
next one I couldn't get to Israel
because you get to Israel uh in middle
of covid it was tough even if you're an
Israeli citizen it was tough to get in
and out of everything kept changing so I
had to do a lot of research for that one
just on my computer and reading books
and then I sent those chapters though
the whole middle part of that last novel
in the blood is in Israel and I sent it
to a family in Israel who had three
generations read it and someone in their
90s someone in their 60s somewhere in
their 30s and they all came back and
said they couldn't believe that I hadn't
been there so that was that's awesome
wow but research a lot of times you
don't know ahead of time even the
outline where something's going to lead
and uh as for this last one a few Point
down a few rabbit holes and I had people
on the podcast who I wouldn't have
normally uh read their book because
there's so much else going on but
they're coming on the podcast so I had
to read the book had to come up with
questions and had a great Converse
conversation and because of that they've
made it in here made it into this last
wow so uh that's that's Brian Moore
that's your real content engine
to have the podcast that I do to connect
with the audience so that I can sell my
book facilitates conversations with
people who end up becoming inspiration
for storylines within the book which I
then sell to the audience that listen to
the podcasts that exactly spoke about it
on a lot more crossover than I initially
anticipated and for the podcast I
thought podcast was just going to be
something I did to I can see a lot of
questions on social media that didn't
really lend themselves to a one sentence
answer uh and so I thought well people
are interested I'll just have a guest on
and talk about this issue and it'll be a
discussion and that'll be great and
provide something of value but there
really is a lot of overlap in the last
two books between the podcast and things
that have made it into these stories and
this one in particular it was Able
Archer in this event in 1983 where we
almost had a nuclear exchange with the
Soviet Union uh and it was just I didn't
I knew a little bit about it but not
nearly as much as I did after I read
those that book which led me to two
other books and then multiple
conversations with Brian Mora about it
so good what about
um National Security issues when writing
and getting clearance and stuff is that
do you ever encounter problems with that
like what if you accidentally come up
with a fictional strategy that the US is
actually trying to use at the moment or
something I guess you can always run
into something like that but for me it
was really the um out of the gate I
wanted to make sure I was just doing the
right thing so I submitted the first one
for review to the Department of Defense
office of pre-publication and Security
review it's called and I was just close
to my time I wrote it during that last
year that I was in the military the
protagonist is a seal but people think
that seals are special operations guys
in general know a bunch of secret stuff
and that really wasn't my experience my
experience was that we're doing
essentially what every major city SWAT
team is going to do tonight they're
going to go server warrant they're gonna
knock on somebody's door or not uh go in
grab them bring them back and that's
really what we did but we did it in
places like uh like Kabul or missoul or
Baghdad or ramadi or whatever whatever
it was but very similar I mean you're
going out with a group with a team you
have a Target get you go in you grab
them you come back and do a little
interrogation and go back out again so
there wasn't really much secret about
that
um but I want to be safe so I submitted
it they took out nine sentences I think
it was not very many and I thought it
was pretty good they said they'd get
back in 30 days and they got back in 45
and I thought well for a huge
bureaucracy that's great so I submitted
the second one True Believer and they
took out they took well I had to push
the publication date because it wasn't
30 days it wasn't 60 it wasn't 90. it
was creeping up on seven months when
they got back so I had to push my
publication date which was not helpful
uh and they took out 54 I want to say 54
either sentences or paragraphs or words
and this time though now I have lawyers
and so I had them tie each one of those
redactions to a publicly available
government document not something that's
on Wikipedia or somebody else's book or
somebody's interview but things that
anyone anywhere on the planet can get on
a government website and download or see
and so they tied every single one of
those all 54 to publicly available U.S
government documents so that defended
you against having them removed uh it's
an appeal so they're removed go to
publication with them removed but now
you have a certain amount of time to
appeal so I appealed and then I won on
37 even though they were all tied they
let me win on 37 so then when the
paperback came out I unredacted them so
now people can compare the hardcover to
the paperback wow government was so
worried about
um and so next book Savage time I do the
same thing and uh this one they get back
I think it was like six months six and a
half five maybe five months at least uh
so I almost had to push publication date
got it back I think they took out let's
say 30 or something like that lines so I
did that same thing I was planning on
doing the same thing I was planning on
having the paperback and unredacting
what they what I won on because we tied
all those things to publicly available
government documents but then they
didn't let me appeal this time they came
back and they said we were even though
we were on time uh ahead of time it was
all done properly they they would not
look at the appeal so now I took that as
them telling me they could quit bugging
us with this fiction stuff we have
important government work to do here so
so yes now I don't uh don't submit which
I'm really glad I don't now because for
the last few books all my research uh if
it's been into National Security space
uh has touched on things that I had no
experience with in the military so for
the devil's hand that's bioweapons
research or what they call biodefense
research to get around certain
conventions that were signed in the 70s
um and then the one right before this
into Ai and Quantum Computing from the
National Intelligence kind of apparatus
how that's being used there so now I'm
really glad that I don't submit them
because they would probably be taking
out things that they shouldn't be taking
out because I didn't learn it through my
government Service uh how interesting
it's so cool that people can get the
paper back and the hardback and do their
own investigative private eye thing to
work out what it was that maybe the
government was a bit concerned about and
now they've they've worked it back and
forth yeah that's so fascinating yeah
there's one location in particular
that's uh and I chose the location
because I'd been there before my time in
the military and I'll tell you what it
is now because I won on the appeal but I
put a CIA black site in Morocco and I
chose Morocco because I'd been there
before my time in the military had such
great memories of it I loved it
Marrakesh I just remember the sights The
Sounds the smells it worked out
geographically for my character to get
where he needed to go so it just it just
works like created it out of whole cloth
I had no never been to Morocco in
uniform or through an intelligence
service or anything like that so uh they
took out all the references to Morocco I
won these this is why I'm talking about
it on appeal but uh they took out
references not just where it said
Morocco they took out Moorish
architecture they took out Atlas
Mountains they took out anything that
could give a hint that so what does that
tell us it tells us that there is
probably a CIA black side in Morocco uh
and if they but if they hadn't even done
that I would I would have thought and
the reader wrote a thought that I just
made it up anyway so I think they uh
maybe maybe this is them playing
five-dimensional chess
I'm pretty sure it's flagging a CIA
black site in Morocco yeah I don't think
so I think my experience in government
service tells me that uh they don't
think that far ahead yeah yeah that's
the nicest way to say it
wow yeah I I find that I find that so
interesting something else that's been
fascinating to me and I noticed this are
you familiar with Sean Ryan have you
been on his show I haven't been on a
show I know who he is but we don't know
each other yeah he's a an absolutely
fantastic guy and he did he moved
through a number of different uh
military services and stuff and I've
noticed this if I bring somebody that is
a Navy SEAL or a Green Beret or a marine
or whatever on the show there is uh one
particular type of interpretation of
that person's career of what they do for
a job of their role etc etc and broadly
it's positive if you bring somebody on
that's ex-fbi or xcia or xnsa
very different very very very different
especially given the fact that many
operatives
phase out of their more kinetic
first job into one of these three letter
agencies to do something that to be
honest as for all that I know as a
British civilian doesn't sound that
dissimilar like it's the same skills
it's maybe a slightly better kit or
slightly cooler kit and it's a bit more
clandestine and there's different
security levels
um what is it why is that the case why
is the Public's interpretation even in a
broadly sort of pro-patriotic pro
military veteran uh audience what is it
do you think that's triggering those
people to have a little bit of
skepticism or distaste for the
three-letter agencies compared with
people who could have gone on to three
letter agencies but just happened to
stop at marine or Green Beret or
whatever yeah I think we're naturally
suspicious of uh Authority particularly
when it comes to agencies in the federal
government that operate under mandates
that uh have a cloak of secrecy attack
matched I think there's generally
generally a more positive outlook on the
military because are you gonna get mad
at the 18 19 20 year old that just went
over and did their job serve food in the
channel line or whatever and now they're
back and whatever whatever it might be
um but then you get into some of these
uh government agencies and we can go
back to not two distant in our nation's
history and go back to the church
hearings or the pike committee hearings
of the 70s that uh unveiled a lot of uh
overreach by different agencies in the
federal government in particular the CIA
um and kind of uh got the dirty laundry
out there for all to see and then of
course there are changes made and and
things that were put in place to
supposedly keep some of those things
from happening again
um so I think there's there's that
natural distrust of a large government
in general and then you add to that uh
oh this agency over here that's doing
things in secret oh you know what else
they did in the past they did these
experiments on U.S citizens yeah they
may have been in a mental institution or
a prison or a part of the military or
college students but they did them and
here's the documentation to prove it uh
here's the testimony in front of
Congress in the 70s so I think there's
just a natural uh skepticism and
distrust there that's not unfounded that
isn't really there with the military
with the military it's more like uh
ineptitude uh when we look at uh the
withdrawal from Afghanistan and I think
really when the when people look at that
they can say you guys had 20 years to
prepare for this and this is your best
you could do like I I don't have any
experience in the military I've never
seen a military movie I've never read a
book on strategy or tactics but I can
look at a map and I can apply common
sense to this problem and I can ask wait
why are we giving up essentially The
High Ground uh here in Bagram and
putting our our young men and women at a
tactically disadvantageous position at
this Airfield why didn't we just leave
out of this other one that seems much
more easily defendable
um and that's a valid question to ask so
I think when we look at the military
it's more and I mean we as a whole it's
more that ineptitude that stands out to
us not necessarily a uh a cloak and
dagger type of a uh of like secret
operations using citizens unbeknownst to
them or surveillance against U.S
citizens or anything like that I think
it's more ineptitude on one side when
you're looking at the military and then
government agencies is a distrust that's
yeah like malice yeah so um it's like
hanland's razor falls on either side
depending on whether you're military or
intelligence service like do not
attribute to malice to that which can be
explained by stupidity the military is
stupid and the the intelligence services
are malicious it's interesting yeah I am
I find that very very fascinating to
think about
um
you know people who join especially tons
of people that join the CIA or the NSA
or the FBI that I'm sure believe that
they are serving their country in the
best way possible it's not easy
necessarily to get into these agencies
hard-working individuals and uh yeah
there's a branding problem man they need
to get they need to get somebody in to
sort out the The Branding and the
interpretation I found this stat earlier
on only 29 of Americans aged 18 to 29
think that patriotism is very important
compared to 62 percent of those aged 65
or older and that is a very recent study
what do you think is happening with the
state of American patriotism at the
moment well I think when I hear those
stats I I attribute that to a um not a
tribute but I think about it in terms of
a a younger generation who hasn't gone
back into the pages of History to
understand why we have the options and
the opportunities and the freedoms that
we have today and what was sacrificed
for us to have this amazing country
um and then there's a lack of
appreciation and a lack of respect for
people from the Inception of this
country up until today who sacrificed
everything so that we could be here
making these decisions that we're making
today really not for us but for the next
generation and the Next Generation the
Next Generation and what's what's
happening now I think and you're so
easily manipulated today so at the same
time that we're not going back in the
pages of history books and you know
might not have a touch point with let's
say the World War II generation because
they're dying off so fast now there's
not that many of them left so you can't
sit across the table and have a meal
with somebody and hear that story from
your grandfather who was there going
over the beach in Iwo Jima or Normandy
uh and you realize that wow this person
did that at age 18 and then what they do
they came home and they got back to work
uh and he worked for all those years we
to provide for my father who in turn
went to college who then allowed us to
live in this house so that and I could
go to school like there's just that that
chain there's a break in the chain as
far as that as that appreciation goes
and that respect uh and just learning
from the pages of of History so uh so
that when we talk about that that stat
that you just just read right there
those percentages anyway
um so I think that's that's a part of it
there's just a disconnect we're farther
away from uh a generation that really
did save the world for all for all
intents and purposes
um and so there's there's that
disconnect there and then you add the
social media to it and they easily how
easily re-manipulated because of these
things that we carry around right now in
our pockets so uh it helps to have a a
little bit of cynicism I think when you
when that thing buzzes and uh Twitter
tells you something an influencer tells
you something a politician tells you
something a news organization tells you
something what do they want to get out
of that they want a response
um so you're being manipulated right
there so at least just to recognize that
I think before immediately really
getting angry and retweeting something
well hey take a breath you owe it to
that person who sacrificed everything
and uh in the Revolutionary War in the
Civil War in World War One in World War
II uh so you could have these freedoms
well take a breath for them and study
the issue a little bit put in that
requisite time energy and effort ah now
make that decision not for you but for
your kid grandkid for those next
Generations so I think a lot of that is
lost in uh in the generation that we
have right now not even the generation
in this fear that we're living in right
now where we are so dependent on
technology for our very mood uh for our
thoughts and behaviors and I think
recognizing it first and then taking
action to correct it if you want to and
then the sad part is people might not
want to correct that they might be very
happy being manipulated from essentially
cradle to grave
um and that's that's not the way I want
to live but uh but it might be once
again Different Strokes who knows well
the incense tips also align to encourage
people to be catastrophic or overblown
or cynical in a negative light or
cynical in a patriotic light or whatever
about a number of issues because that's
what resonates online you know I'm
really fascinated by this sort of
pervasive culture of cynicism that we
have not skepticism that's different
cynicism the world is bad it's not going
to get better and the people that
believe that it can get better are the
ones that are really the problem because
they're giving everybody false hope and
you're a piece of and you shouldn't
listen to you I'm fascinated by it
particularly because
it seems so self-defeating it seems
electing to choose pessimism or cynicism
when optimism is a chance to me uh it
just seems like a very odd road to go
down yet I understand why people do that
because that's what's rewarded on the
Internet it's very easy to look naive on
the internet if you have hope if you
believe that things can get better if
you encourage people to have faith that
things are going to improve it's very
easy for somebody to bring that up in a
couple of months or years time and say
look see it was you that was really the
problem all along there's this almost uh
like intellectual immaturity that can be
thrown at you that you didn't really
understand the truth about the world
it's much easier to get cynical and call
it realism because no one's ever going
to accuse you of being naive
no that's exactly right and it's uh but
it's a tough way gosh it's a tough way
to go and I was talking to somebody
about this not too long ago maybe a week
or two ago and they said hey you have to
remain optimistic because then you'll
never be able to manifest that in the
future and I thought oh that's an
interesting way to so I've been thinking
a lot about about that because you can't
it's easy it's easy to think oh geez how
are we ever going to pull ourselves out
of this we're destroying ourselves from
the inside that's what my fourth book
was about essentially uh it started
being about what the enemies learned on
us tactically on the battlefield in Iraq
and Afghanistan over the last 20 years
at the time and uh and so that's what it
started as and then I started move then
covet hit and I thought oh well the
enemy's learning something about our
response to covid what are they how are
they going to incorporate that how are
they going to use that in their future
battle plans and then a summer of civil
unrest hit hard and I thought well
they're not just taking this in casually
as they walk by the the news feed
they're thinking about how they can
exploit this how can they exploit this
division uh then we had a very
contentious political season uh and once
again they're figuring out how to uh how
to widen those divides and those
fissures and work those into so in doing
all that research and writing that book
for about a year and a half from the
enemy's perspective uh my takeaway was
that geez if I was the enemy I might not
be doing much right now except watching
because we're doing a pretty good job of
destroying ourselves from the inside let
me give you this I've been thinking
about this for so long there's two um
potential explanations for what is
occurring uh to Western anti-westernism
right one of them is that these are
seeds of Discord sown by malign foreign
actors it's the internet research agency
coming out of Russia it's Chinese
misinformation agents and all the rest
of it that's the first one
second one is that Western
anti-westernism is coming endemically
and intrinsically and endogenously from
the West itself
which one is more terrifying
like is it more terrifying that you can
be manipulated by a foreign actor that
sets up a hundred thousand fake Twitter
Bots and then creates a Cascade of
anti-anti patriotism or is it even more
terrifying that this stood on the
sidelines ringing each other going was
this was this thing was this movement
where all of these riots uh oh they
weren't
oh
for oh they're doing it to themselves oh
well yeah grab a coffee let's go for a
drink and um yeah dude those are the two
those are the two options and like both
of them are pretty terrifying to me and
I don't know which one it is yeah if
it's a ladder then uh then the enemy
recognizes that and by the enemy I mean
Russia China and North Korea Iran a
super empowered individual or
individuals uh terrorist organizations
uh what do they need to give a little
nudge just to help it along
let's get a little poke in the back yeah
what's your thoughts you've mentioned
China a couple of times there I know
that you've had Peter Zion on the show
he's been on my show too uh very
impressive and terrifying individual
what is your read on the Chinese threat
uh given the research that you've done
over the last few years yeah well I like
the way he uh articulates it because he
still comes at all these scenarios from
a position of Hope and optimism uh even
where he's deep down into these numbers
and he's looking at uh the China One one
child policy and the same thing in in
Russia um and what they're doing in
their demographics and it knows dive for
ethnic Russians and and all of this but
when it comes to those like Doomsday
type scenarios I really like how he is
very logical about it and uh when we
hear once again it's that manipulation
side of the house when you're we will
throw that nuclear weapon in there we're
talking about Russia Ukraine and he
talks about it from the perspective of
well
you want to take over Ukraine you don't
want to turn it into a nuclear Wasteland
if you want it and you're going to get
to the negotiating table at some point
uh the question is when and that's
that's the question uh then what are you
gonna negotiate out of it what are they
going to get what is Ukraine going to
get what is okay I'm going to use what
is Russia going to lose everybody wins
everybody loses but it's a negotiation
you're going to get there eventually but
you're not going to be able to get
anything but if you use nuclear weapons
of any sort in Ukraine so I like the way
he bring he talks about that and brings
a very sane perspective to it uh same
thing talking about microchips in China
versus microchips in Taiwan and and if
they were to take over Taiwan I wouldn't
know how to continue to create
microchips at the same level because
there's differences between the ones
made in China and the one made ones made
in Taiwan so I like that he brings
things down into these kind of
foundational elements that make sense
logically rather he takes the hysteria
out of it in a way that only began so
he's fascinating and The Accidental
superpower was one that I read on the
way to Mozambique back then in the
summer fall of 2016 when I got out of
the military and really informed my
second novel True Believer but uh but I
love his stuff and I love the way he
presents it and he's just a fascinating
individual so he's probably the most
certain man that I've ever met in my
entire life for the people that haven't
listened to this guy you can go back and
listen to the episode of Modern wisdom
search Peter Zion it's about
z-e-i-h-a-n or I think that you've had
him on your show too and um
he never speaks in caveats he never
speaks with uh there's never any hedging
there's never any uncertainty he is the
most committed man ever and there's a
degree of comfort I can kind of
understand why he's got such a
it's almost rabid his audience online
like they follow him around the internet
they really love Peter and uh I think
that in a world where everybody's quite
uncertain and very few people are
prepared to do the original research
that obviously he has or it seems like
he has to have arrived at the
conclusions that he has done what he
does is he provides
um a degree of safety almost like a
comfort blanket because he gives in a
world of chaos he is able to create some
order he is able to say this is what's
happening this is what will happen this
is why these are the stats that back up
the reason why it's occurring there's no
ifs ands or buts about it no hedging no
no nothing
um but it is very it's very odd to hear
in a way to hear somebody that convicted
about anything is like
yeah because you know I can't counter
him and I just want to learn through our
conversations he's been on twice I think
both of them are the are my uh most
downloaded podcasts I think
um but it is so so certain and very
rarely can I come back and challenge him
on anything because he has done that
research uh correct and put in he knows
those numbers and uh not only does he
know these numbers he knows the history
behind them and where they're going and
how they relate to these other factors
and it's it's I don't know anybody else
that can do it the way he does it it's
very unique
what is the message that you hope people
take away from the book I know that it's
supposed to be you know a thrilling and
entertaining and all the rest of it but
deeper philosophically ethically uh
symbolically what is it that you're
hoping people take away from when they
read your series yeah so there's each
one you can read at a few different
levels and at its base level I want
these just to be time well spent for
someone who's not getting that time back
so that's the main thing it has to be
about has to be about that story every
single time but it can be a different
story for a different different person
if you grab this thing off the shelf in
a Hudson News on the way to your flight
and just read it it's action and
adventure political Intrigue Espionage
awesome and then you move on to the next
one or get back to work when you're when
you're home that's one way
um the other way is to read it a little
bit deeper and that first one especially
but all of them to some extent are
really about someone who becomes the
opposite of what he was so in this case
he becomes the terrorist he becomes the
Insurgent he becomes that person that he
has been training to kill and going out
and to Iraq and Afghanistan over these
years
um and and uh and meeting on the
battlefield he becomes that person now
on home soil
um so they're they're about that and
then a little level deeper than that
they're about somebody who brings the
warshmarak and Afghanistan back to the
front door staff so people who have been
sending young men and women to their
deaths for those 20 years that we were
in Afghanistan so there's a few
different ways that you can read it and
then for me growing up reading all the
Masters reading uh AJ Cornell and JC
Pollock and Mark Olden Town Clancy and
Louis Lamour and David Morrell and
Nelson DeMille and all these guys in the
80s who had these amazing books I would
always find these sentences or maybe it
was a paragraph and it would speak to me
in some way a like oh I should should
know more about that or I'd like to know
more about that but it's just thrown in
there I understand it because of the
context that it's in but obviously the
author has done some more research
that's in there for a reason and now
that's leading me down another path uh
to research this and lead a richer
Fuller life because of it so there's
there's that side of it too but there's
not an underlying message of trying to
sway someone if there is anything like
that it's uh it's it's it's looking at
the protagonist looking at things
through his eyes uh and realizing that
he's a student
um and he's just in this case he's a
student of warfare uh for me I'm a
student of warfare I'm a student of this
craft I was going to say is there a lot
of you do you find a lot of you in the
protagonists I mean he's uh he's got a
background similar to Mine He's a former
Navy SEAL enlisted sniper who became an
officer and and I was a sniper and I
became an officer and uh the reader
meets him at this stage in his life when
he's probably not going to lead guys
tactically on the battlefield anymore
and that's what it was like when I got
back from my last Iraq deployment I
realized that was the last time I
tactically maneuver guys on the
battlefield and going forward it's uh
with me in a staff job somewhere which I
would hate dates and then coming back as
a team commanding officer which sounds
impressive but in today's military
you're really back in a tactical
operations center you're allocating or
if you're more of a manager
um but it sounds impressive but uh but
somebody has to do those jobs just
wasn't me I came in to do that tactical
level job right here
um and did that came home and that's
when I picked my head up looked around
and realized my family needed me we have
a middle child with severe special needs
who needs 24 7 full-time care forever so
I realized that uh that that's my
mission making sure that he's taken care
of him into an author next turn him into
an author right and then it was military
Thrillers there it is there it is and uh
yeah it just gave me that so my mission
was essentially handed to me but my
passion was writing and I got to combine
those two
um but uh but yeah I must I would say
there's yeah there's definitely a lot of
me in James Reese for sure but he's
faster than I am stronger than I am a
better shot than I am better better at
boxing uh he's better at all those
things than I could ever have hoped to
have been
um but he's a student and uh and as am I
so I think that if there's anything that
one could take away from these other
than the underlying underpinnings of the
story that uh is the importance of being
a student
um because that is the the way we
continue to build on whatever
foundations that we have up to this
point uh is by always being a student
whether it's of an industry or of life
in general and that's just the way I
look at things
Jack Carr ladies and gentlemen where
should people go if they want to keep up
to date with all of the stuff that
you're doing at the moment oh man you
are awesome it's uh official jaccar.com
that is the website and you can link
there to Instagram it's Jack carrusa on
Instagram and Twitter which are uh are
still me and I try to say thank you to
everybody and hit that little heart
button because it means so much to me
that people uh really took a risk on me
and allowed me to do what I love which
is the writing so I look at it uh as a
way to do that
um so yeah that's uh the website that
and then danger close podcast of course
and uh then the next the next novels
Only The Dead is out now and as soon as
this week is over I dive back into
number seven and uh start putting uh
some more tweaks on the the Beirut
Barracks bombing non-fiction work that
comes out in about a year and a half
damn right good luck mate I appreciate
you thank you hey thanks so much take
care what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace